- [Conan] We have a very special guest
in the audience tonight.
You gotta give it up, Reed
Richards, of the Fantastic Four,
is sitting in the crowd.
(applause)
- Happy to be here Conan.
Thank you, thanks.
I'm a big fan.
- Okay, I'm glad you're a fan,
Dr. Richards, that's great.
I would ask you please if
you could not sit like that.
All right, it's not really cool.
(laughing)
- Is there a problem, Conan?
(applause)
- Yeah.
There's a problem, yeah.
The theater has certain rules.
Anyone sitting in the
balcony must have their feet
on the floor at all times.
It's for your own safety,
and it wouldn't be fair
to everyone else, you know.
- Well, guess what?
I'm complying with the rules.
My feet are on the floor.
(laughing)
- Okay, no, that's not
what they meant, no.
(laughing)
- Duh, a little help down there.
Can someone scratch my ankle?
- No, no, just leave him, okay.
And of course, no one
helping him. (laughing)
You know you're takin' up a lot of room,
frankly, it's rude, okay.
- I don't hear anyone in
the theater complaining.
Right, we're just havin' fun,
just havin' fun.
(applause)
- Please. Please!
Please, just pull your
arms and legs in, okay?
Please, all right, let's move on.
We have an amazing show tonight.
(laughing)
(applause)
That is not cool, Reed Richards.
- Whoa, why do you assume it's me?
- All right.
(laughing)
Oh, seriously?
(applause)
- Okay, that seriously, that one's me.
That's me.
- Reed Richards, everybody.
(applause)